- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La parole est à madame
Béatrice Descamps.
- Béatrice Descamps: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
du Travail, de la Santé
et des Solidarités.
Je souhaite vous interroger
sur l'octroi
de congés payés
pendant une période
d'arrêt maladie et
sur l'impact
de la rétroactivité
de ce droit
pour l'ensemble
de nos entreprises,
et particulièrement pour les PME.
La Cour de cassation considère,
depuis le 13 septembre dernier,
que les salariés
peuvent acquérir
des congés payés
pendant leur arrêt maladie
suivant ainsi une directive
européenne datée
de 2003 qui n'a pas été
transposée
dans le droit français.
Il n'est pas question
ici de remettre
en cause
le droit des salariés,
mais de pouvoir trouver
des solutions
pour les très petites
entreprises, et les PME
en particulier,
qui sont mises
en difficulté
par cette mesure.
La confédération des PME,
le 17 novembre dernier, demandait
d'ailleurs
dans un communiqué de presse
au gouvernement de limiter
cette rétroactivité,
de plafonner le nombre de jours
de congés payés acquis
dans ce cadre
et de faire en sorte
que le coût
ne soit pas à la seule
charge de l'employeur.
J'ai rencontré
la semaine dernière
un patron d'une
petite entreprise
dans ma circonscription
qui était concerné
par le sujet.
Pour sa salariée,
qui est en arrêt
maladie
depuis trois ans,
il doit débourser
une somme conséquente
qui représente 10%
de sa marge.
Il n'a pas pu faire
la nécessaire
action en amont
pour que cette charge soit étalée.
Si cela se reproduisait,
il pourrait devoir licencier
des personnes
pour pouvoir payer
la somme demandée.
Il semble que le gouvernement
de madame Borne ait
bien identifié ce problème
et ait souhaité
se mettre en conformité
avec le droit européen,
tout en veillant
à préserver son impact
sur les entreprises.
Je souhaiterais
donc savoir
où en sont vos travaux
et comment
vous comptez
assurer les droits
des salariés
tout en préservant
les petites et moyennes
entreprises
pour lesquelles
plus l'attente est longue,
plus les difficultés s'accumulent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Catherine Vautrin.
- Catherine Vautrin: Merci.
Madame la députée
Béatrice Descamps,
merci
de revenir sur cet arrêt
de la Cour de cassation du 13
septembre dernier qui,
effectivement,
est un arrêt extrêmement
important puisqu'il met
en avant le fait
que la législation française
n'est pas en conformité
avec le droit européen.
Il s'agit de la capacité
pour les salariés des entreprises
de continuer
à acquérir des jours
de congés
alors même qu'ils sont en arrêt
de travail,
quelles que soient la durée
et la pathologie.
A partir de là,
je me permettrai
de rajouter un élément
de contexte.
Il y a une question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité
qui a été déposée,
dont nous ne connaissons pas,
aujourd'hui, la réponse du Conseil
constitutionnel,
un élément important
dans notre réflexion.
Pour le reste, notre pays
se mettra en conformité
avec la législation européenne.
Les conséquences
financières sont évidemment
très importantes
pour les entreprises,
les TPE, les PME
et l'ensemble de nos entreprises.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle
nous ne pouvons
que travailler
avec l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux,
c'est-à-dire les représentants
des salariés
et les représentants
des entreprises.
C'est en tout cas le sens
dans lequel
je souhaite aller,
dans un délai
qui sera évidemment
le plus court possible,
eu égard à cette grande
interrogation
pour les entreprises
et les salariés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Xavier Breton.
- Xavier Breton: Merci.
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
nous avons été nombreux
à être profondément choqués
à la mi-décembre
par la décision
du président de la Cour
des comptes de différer,
de repousser
la publication d'un rapport
sur l'immigration,
rapport particulièrement sévère
par rapport à la politique
de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière.
Pour tenter d'expliquer
cette décision,
le président
de la plus haute juridiction
des comptes publics
a indiqué
benoîtement
qu'il ne souhaitait pas
influencer
le vote des parlementaires.
Mais quelle conception
monsieur Moscovici
se fait-il des députés
et des sénateurs?
Considère-t-il
que nous ne soyons
pas assez matures
pour prendre connaissance
et pour analyser un rapport?
Juge-t-il
que nous nous serions
pas capables
de comprendre les écrits
et la pensée des magistrats
de la rue Cambon?
Si nombre de nos concitoyens
ont également été choqués,
c'est parce qu'ils y retrouvent
le mépris
de cette prétendue
élite technocratique
à l'égard des représentants
du peuple.
Notre président de groupe,
Olivier Marleix,
vient de demander
au président
de la commission
des finances
qu'il organise
l'audition du président
de la Cour des comptes.
Du côté du gouvernement,
nous attendons
une condamnation ferme.
Est-ce que vous désapprouvez
le mépris du président
de la Cour
des comptes
à l'égard du Parlement
et qui va à l'encontre
de nos institutions?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Marie Lebec.
- Marie Lebec: Merci.
Monsieur le député Xavier Breton,
merci
pour cette question.
Avant de démarrer
ma réponse, je voudrais excuser
le ministre Gérald Darmanin
qui est en déplacement
à La Réunion
aux côtés
de nos compatriotes suite
au passage du cyclone.
Vous interrogez
le gouvernement
sur le rapport
de la Cour des comptes
sur la politique de lutte
sur l'immigration irrégulière
publié le 14 janvier 2024.
La Cour des comptes
est une juridiction financière
dont l'indépendance est garantie
constitutionnellement.
Elle définit
en toute indépendance
le programme
de ses contrôles
et leur déroulement.
Il n'appartient
donc pas au gouvernement
de se prononcer
sur le calendrier
et la date de publication
de ce rapport.
Sur le fond de votre question,
le gouvernement
se félicite
que la Cour
souligne que la France
soit le pays d'Europe
qui exécute
le plus d'éloignements forcés
en Europe, avec plus de 14.000
éloignements forcés
en 2022 pour la France.
La priorité est donnée
à l'éloignement
des étrangers
constituant une menace
pour le pays.
Les constats formulés
par ce rapport
sur les leviers
à activer pour améliorer
le nombre de reconduites
sont assez largement connus.
D'autres rapports
ont été menés
par l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat
à son sujet.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle le projet
de loi initial
du gouvernement déposé
au Sénat le 1er février
2023 comprenait déjà
des mesures fortes
pour lever ces blocages
pour simplifier
les contentieux,
lever les protections
dont bénéficient certains
étrangers qui constituent
une menace
à l'ordre public
ou encore alléger
les charges
pour les policiers
et les gendarmes.
L'orientation
du gouvernement
est de lutter
contre l'immigration irrégulière.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur Breton?
- Xavier Breton:
Merci, madame la ministre,
pour cette réponse.
Ce rapport est très sévère
sur la politique
contre l'immigration
irrégulière,
mais la question,
c'est le rôle
de la Cour des comptes
dans nos institutions.
Vous évoquez son indépendance.
On remarquera
que le président est nommé
par le président de la République.
Je voudrais citer
l'article 47-2
qui dit que la Cour
des comptes assiste
le Parlement
dans le contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement
ainsi que dans l'évaluation
des politiques publiques.
Manifestement,
ils ont manqué
à leur devoir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Agnès Carel.
- Agnès Carel: Merci.
Ma question s'adressait
au ministre
de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer,
qui est absent,
puisqu'il a dû se rendre
à La Réunion en raison
des événements météorologiques.
Ma question s'adressera
donc à madame
la ministre
de l'Education nationale,
de la Jeunesse,
des Sports et des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques.
Après une année 2023
particulièrement intense,
l'année 2024 s'annonce
très chargée
pour l'ensemble
de nos forces de l'ordre,
avec les Jeux Olympiques
et Paralympiques,
mais aussi avec le parcours
de la flamme,
sans oublier le 80e
anniversaire
du Débarquement
en Normandie
et bien d'autres
événements prévus,
mais aussi ceux inattendus.
Pour ne citer qu'un
exemple, l'unité
de CRS installée
dans ma circonscription,
à côté du Havre,
a été mobilisée 235 jours
en 2023, bien
plus que l'année précédente,
avec des déplacements
de plus en plus lointains
comme Grenoble, Marseille ou Nice.
L'année 2024 s'annonce
tout aussi chargée face
à un calendrier
complexe
pour eux et leurs familles.
Si tous les membres
de nos forces
de l'ordre sont engagés
avec professionnalisme,
et ils m'en ont d'ailleurs
fait part récemment,
il n'en demeure pas
moins que leurs inquiétudes
se focalisent
notamment sur la prise
en charge
de leurs enfants
pendant leur affectation
durant les JO,
et c'est bien compréhensible.
La quasi-totalité
d'entre
eux ne pourront pas
prétendre
à des vacances
pendant cette période estivale.
Il serait normal que leurs enfants
soient prioritaires
pour accéder aux centres
de loisirs, centres aérés,
crèches et garderies,
mais aussi colonies
de vacances,
afin
qu'ils ne soient pas privés
de loisirs
pendant cette période
où leurs parents seront pleinement
mobilisés.
Quelles mesures compte prendre
le gouvernement,
en lien
avec les représentants
de ces professions,
pour rassurer
ces professionnels
qui sont aussi
des parents afin
qu'ils exercent
leurs fonctions l'esprit rassuré?
Notre gouvernement
leur doit bien
en amont...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, ma chère collègue.
La parole est à madame
Amélie Oudéa-Castéra.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra: Merci.
Madame la députée Carel,
votre question
est
l'opportunité pour moi
de saluer l'ensemble des forces
de sécurité intérieure
pour leur mobilisation
exceptionnelle
tout au long
de l'année au service
de la société,
au service de l'école
et au service
du sport.
La réussite des JO repose
sur une mobilisation
exceptionnelle
des agents du ministère
de l'Intérieur,
en particulier nos policiers
et gendarmes.
Pour la seule cérémonie
d'ouverture, 45.000 d'entre
eux seront sur le terrain.
Il leur sera demandé
une présence maximale
entre le 15 juin
et le 15 septembre,
allant jusqu'à 100%
au coeur de l'événement,
du 24 juillet au 11 août.
Pour concilier engagements
et vie personnelle,
le ministre
de l'Intérieur a annoncé
aux agents qu'ils pourraient
prendre jusqu'à
deux semaines de congés
sur cette période.
Au-delà de cet enjeu des congés,
Gérald Darmanin a reçu
les organisations syndicales
de gardiens
de la paix ce lundi
pour entendre
leurs autres demandes.
S'agissant de la rémunération,
il présentera d'ici
la fin du mois de janvier
l'accompagnement prévu
en termes de primes
et de paiement
des heures supplémentaires.
Des annonces seront faites
sur les dispositifs d'action
sociale qui permettront
l'accueil
de la petite enfance
et les séjours
pour les enfants,
ce qui sera particulièrement
précieux pour les familles
monoparentales
ou les couples d'agents mobilisés.
Tout ce travail
sur l'aménagement
du temps de travail
et l'accompagnement
des familles
est également conduit
par chaque ministère,
par tous les ministères
pour tous leurs agents
mobilisés
pendant les Jeux Olympiques.
Votre question
est l'occasion de saluer
tous ces agents, les remercier.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Christine Engrand.
- Christine Engrand:
En 2012, au Sénat,
un cadre au sein
du service de l'Etat
hollandais dédié
à la gestion de l'eau
expliquait que la clé
de notre réussite résidait
moins dans les ouvrages
que dans notre système
organisationnel,
légal et financier.
Force est de constater
que, 12 ans
plus tard,
l'échec du gouvernement,
le désarroi
des milliers
de personnes inondées
à deux reprises est bien
organisationnel,
légal et financier.
Vous ne savez pas quoi
faire pour sortir
de la crise.
Vous n'êtes pas compétents.
Le droit européen vous empêche.
Vous ne savez pas quoi faire.
Sinon,
vous n'auriez pas attendu
deux mois avant de préciser
les conditions d'éligibilité
des agriculteurs
aux indemnisations
pour les pertes de récoltes.
Les maraîchers
ne sont pas inclus
dans les dispositifs d'aide.
L'UE vous empêche.
Vous leur faites
un cadeau empoisonné.
Vous débloquez les aides
que le droit européen plafonne
à 20.000 euros
sur trois années
par exploitation.
Autrement dit,
entravés par l'UE,
vous anéantissez
les possibilités
pour les maraîchers français,
qui seront indemnisés
de leur sinistre,
pendant les trois prochaines
années.
Cela aurait pu
être évité
si vous aviez agi
lors des premières inondations.
L'indemnisation
des calamités agricoles
est permise par les traités.
Si les conditions
pour déclencher
ces calamités
agricoles
n'étaient pas réunies,
vous pouviez
tout de même monter
une aide dédiée
aux sinistres.
Alors, peut-être
que nos maraîchers bénéficieraient
aujourd'hui d'une
aide pour indemniser
les dégâts d'une
catastrophe naturelle
contre laquelle
ils n'ont
même pas la possibilité
de s'assurer.
Une fois de plus,
la décision finale revient
à l'Union Européenne.
Monsieur le ministre,
que vont devenir
tous ces gens
dont vous vous apprêtez
à saboter l'activité?
Une France souveraine
ne se poserait
même pas la question
avec une Europe
des nations.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot: Merci.
Madame la députée Engrand,
je profite
de votre question
et, à ce titre,
je vous remercie
pour votre question
et je salue l'ensemble
des hommes
et des femmes
qui se sont mobilisés
dans le cadre
de ces inondations
exceptionnelles
qui ont eu lieu aussi bien
en novembre dernier qu'en
ce début d'année
dans le département
du Pas-de-Calais
et à l'ouest du département
du Nord.
Je salue nos forces
nationales
que sont
les forces de sécurité
et de secours,
mais également l'ensemble
des élus locaux.
Permettez-moi aussi
d'avoir un mot,
puisque vous avez parlé
d'Europe,
non pas
pour les dénoncer,
mais pour saluer le travail
de nos amis slovaques,
notamment polonais,
qui sont venus en renfort
de nos populations nationales.
Je pense qu'il est aussi
important
de rappeler
que l'Europe
n'est pas un ennemi,
mais bien une démarche
de solidarité.
Si, c'est la question.
Ca vous gêne,
mais je vais le répéter.
Oui, l'Europe,
nous devons en être fiers,
notamment quand elle vient
en renfort
de la France.
Des travaux de remise
en état des cours d'eau
et canaux ont été
engagés dès lundi,
notamment le curage
de certains cours d'eau,
l'achat d'une station
de pompage installée
dans une commune financée
par le fonds vert
et le fonds Barnier est d'ores
et déjà programmé.
Nous avons demandé
aux services d'inspection
de l'Etat de procéder
à trois missions d'évaluation.
La première vise à estimer
les dégâts causés sur les biens
de collectivités.
La seconde a été
confiée au maire
de Saint-Omer.
La troisième vise
à travailler
sur la prévention des inondations.
Par ailleurs, ce sujet
est hautement important.
Le premier déplacement
du Premier ministre,
Gabriel Attal,
a été fait justement
dans ce département,
sur ce territoire.
Comme il l'a dit,
il ira à la fin
du mois et au début
du mois prochain
pour être aux côtés
des populations sinistrées.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
le président Davy Rimane.
- Davy Rimane: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur
et des
Outre-mer est aujourd'hui
aux abonnés absents,
mais nous ne lui en tiendrons pas
rigueur
car il est aux côtés
de nos compatriotes réunionnais.
Nous leur adressons
notre solidarité.
Quant à l'audace,
cette fameuse audace que le
président de la République
nous présente
comme la ligne directrice
de cette nouvelle ère macronienne,
elle est décrédibilisée
d'entrée
de jeu car pas téméraire.
La vraie audace aurait été
de rétablir un ministère
de plein exercice
dédié à tout ce qui constitue
les singularités
qui font nos territoires
transocéaniques.
Les nombreuses questions
ultramarines restent
sur le banc de touche.
Pas un mot
pour les outre-mer
lors de l'allocution
d'Emmanuel Macron.
Je m'adresse à vous,
monsieur le Premier ministre.
Où en sommes-nous?
Vous êtes censé
incarner le renouveau,
mais la question
des outre-mer n'a
jamais été abordée
depuis sept ans,
sauf en réaction
aux catastrophes naturelles,
aux pénuries d'eau,
aux interpellations
d'exécutifs locaux.
Je voudrais vous donner
une feuille
de route
pour les outre-mer,
pour la valorisation
de leur diversité culturelle,
humaine, linguistique,
pour la reconnaissance
de la population et les dissuader
de voter Le Pen en 2027.
Je vous donne ici l'occasion
de ne plus être
en réaction,
mais dans l'action.
Vous avez dit
lors de votre nomination
que vous amèneriez
l'éducation à Matignon avec vous.
Comptez-vous amener
les outre-mer
à Matignon également?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Monsieur le président Davy Rimane,
vous
n'êtes pas
président de groupe,
mais je tenais à vous répondre
personnellement.
Le sujet que vous abordez
est absolument majeur.
Je compte conduire
mon action
en tant que Premier
ministre de la France
avec mon gouvernement.
Ces dernières années,
j'ai eu l'occasion d'occuper
différentes fonctions
gouvernementales,
en tant que secrétaire
d'Etat à la jeunesse,
de porte-parole
du gouvernement,
ministre des Comptes publics
et de l'Education nationale.
A chaque fois,
j'ai eu l'opportunité
et la chance
de travailler
avec nos territoires
ultramarins
sur tous ces enjeux.
Je suis lucide,
à la fois sur les immenses défis
qui sont devant nous pour ces
territoires
en matière de logement,
en matière sociale,
en matière d'emploi, de mobilité,
d'immigration aussi,
en matière environnementale,
mais lucide aussi
de la chance extraordinaire
que constitue
les territoires
ultramarins
pour notre pays,
en matière de jeunesse,
d'innovation,
de créativité, de souveraineté,
de biodiversité.
Je le dis de manière très claire:
oui, il faut être aux côtés
de nos territoires ultramarins
lorsque surviennent
des drames
et des crises.
C'est à ce titre
que mon ministre
de l'Intérieur,
Gérald Darmanin,
est en ce moment
même à La Réunion
aux côtés des victimes du cyclone,
mais il faut aussi,
et vous avez raison
de le dire,
être dans la prospective,
investir positivement
sur tous les potentiels
de nos territoires ultramarins.
Nous avons un certain nombre
d'échéances majeures
devant nous.
Le président
de la République
avait annoncé
il y a quelques mois
la préparation
d'une grande loi
sur Mayotte.
Nous allons y travailler.
De la même manière,
nous avons des textes
institutionnels
importants sur l'avenir
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
qui nous rassembleront ici,
dans cet hémicycle.
Je sais qu'en Guyane,
aux Antilles,
à La Réunion, à Mayotte,
à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon,
Wallis-et-Futuna,
dans tous nos territoires
ultramarins,
il y a des défis
et des enjeux sur lesquels
nous devons investir ensemble.
Je recevrai aussi
vite que possible
la délégation
aux outre-mer
que vous présidez.
Je réunirai
dans les prochains mois
un comité interministériel
aux outre-mer
pour avancer sur tous
ces sujets-là.
Je me rendrai aussi
vite que possible
dans nos territoires
ultramarins
et j'espère
que vous me ferez l'honneur
de m'accompagner
dans ce déplacement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur le président?
- Davy Rimane:
Le rendez-vous est pris.
Sachez quand même
qu'il y a des urgences
et des scandales à régler
sur nos territoires,
au risque de fractures
irréversibles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Faure.
- Olivier Faure: Merci.
"On allait voir
ce qu'on allait voir."
Le président
a convoqué hier soir
les Français pour, je cite,
"son grand rendez-vous
avec la nation",
mais sur quoi unit-on
une nation
et sur quelle vision
pour que la France
reste la France?
La France
républicaine
n'est pas une nostalgie.
Elle est un horizon.
La volonté chaque jour
renouvelée d'avancer
sur le chemin de la liberté,
de l'égalité
et de la fraternité est bien là.
Les crises se multiplient.
Elles se cumulent.
Les inégalités explosent.
C'était le moment
de responsabiliser
le CAC 40 avec un discours
de vérité
en appelant les plus riches
à l'effort national
pour répondre
aux défis de l'avenir.
Le voilà, le vrai
réarmement civique.
L'école a besoin
de nouveaux hussards
de la République, pas d'uniformes.
Rendez à nouveau attractif
le plus beau métier
du monde.
Soutenez l'école publique!
Le travail doit payer.
Il faut une grande
conférence sociale
où tout serait remis
à plat pour augmenter
les salaires, à commencer
par les premiers
de corvée.
Le logement, un toit
pour tous devrait
être la règle
alors que plus de 3 millions
de logements restent
aujourd'hui vacants.
L'accès aux soins: il est
temps d'en finir
avec les déserts médicaux,
de réguler l'installation
des médecins
comme c'est le cas
pour les pharmaciens.
La bifurcation écologique:
vos propres experts
ont exigé des moyens.
Rétablissez un ISF climatique!
La démocratie,
c'est d'abord le pluralisme.
Interdisez la concentration
des médias.
Garantissez l'indépendance
des rédactions!
J'en finis par vous,
monsieur le Premier ministre.
Vous ne pouvez pas être le simple
collaborateur
d'un président à bout de souffle.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le député.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Faure, j'avoue
être un peu perplexe.
Je m'attendais
à une question
et en réalité,
j'assiste à un simulacre
de discours de politique générale.
Soit, allons-y.
Allons-y, vous qui n'avez bien
évidemment jamais été
aux responsabilités,
vous qui n'avez
jamais pu faire
des choses
pour la France,
que ce soit ici,
ailleurs, aujourd'hui
ou avant.
Mais regardons
les sujets dans le fond
parce que les gens
n'attendent pas
que l'on crie,
mais plutôt qu'on leur réponde.
Nous avons aujourd'hui
cette responsabilité
de pouvoir parler
des sujets de fond.
Vous parlez de redistribution.
Oui,
nous sommes un des pays
où il y a le plus
de redistribution.
Cette redistribution
existe
parce qu'il y a effectivement
des personnes
qui peuvent distribuer,
qui peuvent participer
à cette redistribution
et cette solidarité nationale.
Ce n'est pas en pointant
du doigt
qu'on y arrivera
et qu'on arrivera
à créer cette cohésion
nationale
dont on a tant besoin
en ce moment.
Vous parlez d'augmenter
les salaires.
Oui et encore oui,
monsieur Faure,
mais pour augmenter
les salaires,
encore faut-il
que les emplois existent,
et c'est ce à quoi
nous nous sommes employés
dès 2017,
à lutter
contre un fléau
que vous avez renoncé
à étudier
et que vous avez considéré
comme une fatalité
qui s'appelle le chômage
de longue durée
et le chômage de masse.
C'est une réalité.
Vous pouvez souffler,
nous l'avons fait.
Je pense
qu'aujourd'hui,
même si vous faites partie
d'un groupe d'opposition,
nous pouvons
encore nous retrouver
pour travailler
ensemble,
non pas pour travailler
sur les egos.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Céline Calvez.
- Céline Calvez: Merci.
Madame la ministre
de la Culture,
votre nomination
a été une surprise
pour certains.
Beaucoup, même.
Les mêmes
sont déjà surpris
par votre détermination
pour vous battre
pour l'accès à la culture.
C'est un véritable
moyen d'émancipation
et d'égalité.
La majorité
présidentielle s'y essaye
depuis 2017,
avec notamment la mise
en place du pass culture.
Hier,
le président
de la République
y a d'ailleurs
fait référence
et souhaite renforcer
cela par le théâtre
et l'histoire
de l'art à l'école.
Il a aussi fait
référence au rôle
des célébrations,
nos hommages qui rappellent
et constituent
progressivement
notre mémoire collective.
Vous prenez
vos fonctions en 2024,
quand le monde aura
plusieurs occasions
de nous regarder,
nous, la France,
dans des événements
de fierté majeure:
les Jeux Olympiques
et Paralympiques,
la réouverture de Notre-Dame,
le 80e anniversaire
du Débarquement
ou encore le Sommet
de la francophonie.
Comment faire
que la culture rayonne
pour tous, ici et en dehors
de nos frontières,
en même temps que l'accès
à la culture partout
et pas qu'à Paris?
C'est grâce aux artistes,
aux festivals,
aux associations
que je souhaite remercier
pour leur action partout,
tout le temps.
L'accès partout,
c'est aussi le contexte culturel
permis par l'audiovisuel
et le numérique.
Quelle place accorderez-vous
à ces créations?
Comment tirer
le meilleur avantage
de leur pouvoir de diffusion
et d'interaction
sans les risques de leurs dérives?
Vous défendez
la culture populaire.
Derrière cette notion,
je veux
vous adresser une question:
comment souhaitez-vous oeuvrer
pour la reconnaissance
de la culture
de chacune et chacun d'entre nous?
Comment votre feuille de route
s'inscrira-t-elle
dans tous ces défis?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Rachida Dati.
Huées et applaudissements
- Rachida Dati:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs les députés,
madame la députée,
chère Céline, au moment où
je prends la tête
du ministère
de la Culture, je trouve
deux grandes questions.
La première:
comment consolider
notre modèle culturel?
Comment le soutenir
tout en soutenant
tous les acteurs
du monde de la culture
dans un monde
qui bouge rapidement
et qui peut
être extrêmement menaçant?
D'autre part,
comment faire en sorte
que notre modèle
culturel soit au coeur
de notre modèle de société?
On voit tous les jours
combien
il est remis
en cause, notamment
par certains de ce côté-là
de l'hémicycle.
Dans notre pays, trop de jeunes
se disent
encore que le théâtre,
les musées
et la lecture,
ce n'est pas pour eux.
La lecture,
c'est ce qui permet à chacun
de se construire.
C'est ce qui permet à chacun
de devenir un citoyen éclairé.
Je le sais justement
par mon expérience.
Moi, je n'ai hérité de rien,
monsieur Marleix.
Je sais par mon expérience...
Je sais que l'émancipation,
je sais,
ça ne vous parle pas,
je sais
que la liberté passe
par la culture.
Cette chance doit
être offerte
à tous et partout sur tous
les territoires.
Voilà la mission
que m'a confiée
le président de la République.
Je vous le dis,
je l'accomplirai
avec détermination,
avec honneur, partout
sur le territoire
et avec vous tous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
madame la ministre.
Un peu de silence,
s'il vous plaît.
La parole est à madame
Danièle Obono.
- Danièle Obono: Merci.
Le 29 décembre 2023,
l'Afrique du Sud
a déposé devant la cour
internationale
de justice,
en vertu
de la convention de 1948
pour la prévention
et la répression
du crime de génocide,
une requête
contre Israël concernant
les exactions commises
par son gouvernement
de droite
contre la population
palestinienne
de Gaza.
Le 11 janvier 2024,
les plaidoiries
de la république
sud-africaine
ont fait l'objet
d'un scandale au boycott
des médias occidentaux
et français.
Il s'agissait pourtant
d'un événement historique
à la portée inédite.
Les gouvernements occidentaux,
qui n'ont de cesse
de donner des leçons
de démocratie
et de droits humains
au reste du monde,
font preuve de complaisance
à son égard
quand il ne lui apporte
pas un soutien
militaire et financier
comme les Etats-Unis d'Amérique.
C'est l'Afrique du Sud,
la nation arc-en-ciel
qui a subi l'esclavage,
la colonisation
et l'apartheid,
dont le peuple a construit
sa liberté à hauteur d'une
très longue lutte
de libération nationale,
c'est ce pays africain
qui a sauvé
notre honneur à tous
et toutes en défendant
à la fois
la cause du peuple
palestinien,
celle du droit international
et de l'humanité
tout entière.
Nous lui en sommes profondément
reconnaissantes
et reconnaissants.
A Gaza, expliquait
une des avocates,
se déroule le premier
génocide de l'histoire
dont les victimes
diffusent en temps réel
leur propre destruction,
dans l'espoir désespéré
de voir le monde
faire quelque chose.
Si elle veut
être en cohérence
avec ses valeurs,
la France doit urgemment emboîter
le pas à l'Afrique du Sud,
comme l'ont déjà
fait plus de 50
pays dans le monde.
Elle doit soutenir
la requête sud-africaine
qui demande notamment
à la cour internationale
de justice d'enjoindre
le gouvernement israélien
à suspendre immédiatement
ses opérations militaires.
Elle doit également appliquer
au niveau national
et européen des sanctions
qui s'imposent.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, l'histoire
nous regarde.
Elle ne sera pas
tendre
avec celles
et ceux qui savaient
et n'ont rien fait.
Plus jamais ça pour personne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Stéphane Séjourné.
- Stéphane Séjourné: Merci.
Madame la députée Obono,
le 7 octobre dernier, Israël
a subi une attaque
terroriste barbare.
1200 morts,
des mutilations,
des viols,
des assassinats d'enfants,
des civils israéliens
qui ont été visés
pour ce qu'ils sont.
41 Français sont morts
dans ces conditions atroces.
Nous leur rendrons
hommage le 7 février.
Trois encore
de nos compatriotes
sont otages à Gaza
et nous faisons
tout pour les en sortir.
Qu'avez-vous dit en réaction
à ces crimes terroristes?
Je vous cite:
"Le Hamas est un groupe
de résistance
qui se définit comme tel."
C'est ça, le scandale.
Le président de la République
a toujours tenu
une position
d'équilibre,
je vous la rappelle:
condamner le terrorisme,
ce que vous n'arrivez
toujours pas
à faire, madame
Obono, il a oeuvré
à un cessez-le-feu
immédiat pour permettre
de garantir...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le ministre!
Deux secondes.
Est-ce que vous pourriez
faire silence
et écouter la réponse,
s'il vous plaît?
Je vous en remercie.
Vous ne choisissez pas
vos réponses,
ils ne choisissent pas
leurs questions.
Monsieur le ministre,
nous vous écoutons.
- Stéphane Séjourné:
Nous devons rétablir
un horizon politique
pour avancer vers deux Etats.
Pour ce qui est de la cour
internationale
de justice,
puisque c'est votre question,
nous disons fermement
aux Israéliens que le respect
du droit s'impose
à tous et que les frappes
systématiques
à Gaza doivent cesser,
mais les mots ont un sens,
madame Obono.
Accuser l'Etat
juif de génocide,
c'est franchir un seuil moral.
On ne peut exploiter
la notion de génocide
à des fins politiques.
C'est notre position constante.
Nous l'avons dit
quand la Russie a utilisé
ce justificatif pour justifier
l'injustifiable,
sa guerre en Ukraine.
Madame la présidente,
j'ai été interrompu.
Nous n'avons pas de leçons
à recevoir
de votre parti.
Vous n'êtes pas au clair
ni sur le Hamas,
ni sur Gaza.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
Madame Obono, s'il vous plaît.
La parole est à madame
Julie Laernoes.
- Julie Laernoes:
Ma question s'adresse
à Bruno Le Maire,
ministre de l'Economie,
et donc maintenant
aussi ministre
de l'Energie.
Où est passé le climat?
Complètement absent
du grand oral
du président de la République,
complètement absent aussi
du remaniement ministériel.
Le climat
a tout simplement disparu.
Pourtant, le réchauffement
climatique, lui,
n'a pas disparu.
2023 a été l'année la plus chaude
jamais enregistrée.
Inondations,
canicules, incendies,
les catastrophes
se multiplient
et les habitants
du Pas-de-Calais
en sont les dernières victimes.
Et que faites-vous?
Rien.
A défaut d'agir,
vous prétendez
être les premiers
en Europe à vous emparer
de l'adaptation
au réchauffement climatique.
Mais de qui se moque-t-on?
La seule action de monsieur
Christophe Béchu
est de courir
pour constater les dégâts.
La fenêtre de tir
se referme
de plus en plus vite
et que faites-vous?
Rien.
Votre première
action, monsieur
Bruno Le Maire,
comme ministre de l'Energie,
est de supprimer le climat
et les énergies renouvelables
de la loi.
L'écologie ne sert
visiblement
plus le discours
politique de la macronie
pour contrer l'extrême droite.
Ordre, armement,
uniformes, immigration...
Au contraire,
vous avez définitivement décidé
de vous réapproprier
le vocabulaire
de l'extrême droite
et l'écologie,
de fait, n'y
a pas sa place.
Une régression totale,
complète et coupable.
La priorité
politique devrait
être de baisser
la consommation,
de rénover nos logements,
de faire payer
les plus gros
pollueurs comme Total,
mais vous, vous laissez
la situation
se dégrader
dans l'indifférence
pour protéger votre sacro-sainte
croissance économique
et faire diversion
avec des solutions
technosolutionnistes,
avec en tête le nucléaire.
Exit la sobriété,
exit les renouvelables,
exit les associations
environnementales,
exit les normes européennes
et climatiques.
Un retour en arrière de 17 ans
absolument terrifiant
à rebours de la réalité
scientifique.
Assumez-vous
aujourd'hui
d'être les meilleurs amis
des climato-sceptiques?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Madame la députée,
je veux vous rassurer,
les résultats sont là
et sont incontestables.
La France a réduit
ses émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de 4%.
C'est le pays
qui a le plus accéléré
sur sa réduction
d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre.
Vous regardez
toutes les nations européennes
et vous regardez
le pays qui émet
le moins de tonnes
de CO2 par unité
de production industrielle,
vous trouvez
quel pays?
La France,
qui est le pays
le plus vertueux
du point de vue
de ses émissions
de gaz à effet de serre en Europe.
Vous regardez
notre mix énergétique
et vous constatez
que le pays
qui a le mix énergétique
le plus favorable
à la lutte
contre le réchauffement
climatique,
c'est une nouvelle fois
la France.
Madame
la députée,
ne doutez pas de ma détermination
totale
à accélérer
la transition climatique
dans les nouvelles
fonctions
qui sont les miennes
et à faire en sorte
que notre énergie
soit l'énergie
la plus décarbonée en Europe.
Nous tenons nos objectifs:
50% de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre d'ici 2030
et la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050,
avec un troisième
objectif que j'ajoute,
à savoir être la première nation
industrielle décarbonée
en Europe à échéance 2040.
Je n'ai qu'un seul mot,
mais il devrait rassurer:
accélérer.
Accélérer
sur la sobriété,
vous avez raison.
C'est un point
absolument majeur
de la stratégie climatique
qui a été définie
par le président de la République.
Je commence volontairement par là.
Oui, la sobriété est nécessaire.
Oui, l'efficacité
énergétique est nécessaire
parce que personne ne peut
accepter qu'une industrie
ne mette
une énergie
sans qu'elle soit récupérée
pour réduire
les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre.
Oui, nous allons accélérer
sur les renouvelables,
sur les panneaux
photovoltaïques,
sur l'éolien,
sur la géothermie,
sur les pompes
à chaleur,
sur tout ce qui permet
de gagner
cette bataille du climat.
Nous allons accélérer aussi
sur la réalisation
des six nouveaux EPR
car c'est de l'énergie décarbonée
et c'est aussi
une victoire
contre le réchauffement
climatique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Enfin, la parole
est à madame Marina Ferrari.
- Marina Ferrari: Merci.
Ma question porte
sur l'assurance
des collectivités.
Nos collectivités
sont confrontées
à des difficultés pour s'assurer.
La situation en 2024
est très préoccupante.
Il y a quelques mois,
ces difficultés portaient
davantage sur l'assurance
statutaire
et sur les villes
petites et moyennes
dans certaines zones
très exposées.
Toutes les strates
des collectivités
sont aujourd'hui concernées.
2000 d'entre elles seraient
sans couverture.
Dans mon département
de la Savoie,
une enquête montre que 33%
des communes interrogées
sont confrontées
à la résiliation unilatérale
de leur contrat,
à l'augmentation
des prix de 25 à 100%,
en particulier
sur les dommages aux biens,
la responsabilité civile
et les flottes automobiles.
Nos collectivités
sont donc conduites
à s'auto-assurer avec des risques
financiers énormes.
Cette situation
s'explique par un marché
de l'assurance
qui est déficitaire,
une sinistrabilité
de plus en plus importante,
mais aussi une sinistrabilité
climatique
qui explose.
Le coût des dégâts
des catastrophes naturelles
pourrait atteindre 3
milliards d'euros
par an d'ici 2050.
Pour autant, l'Etat
n'est pas resté sourd
et a annoncé des mesures.
Une mission gouvernementale
sur l'assurabilité
des collectivités a été nommée.
Ses conclusions
sont attendues
pour fin avril
et conduirons certainement
à un travail législatif.
J'aurai une pensée
pour mes compatriotes
du Pas-de-Calais
et La Réunion
et pour leurs élus
locaux
qui sont en première
ligne dans la gestion
de l'après.
Au moment où les discussions
budgétaires
sont en cours
dans nos communes,
comment l'Etat
compte-t-il travailler
sur ce sujet
avec les représentants
des associations d'élus?
Comment envisagez-vous
le soutien
aux collectivités
qui se trouvent
sans couverture assurancielle?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot:
Madame la députée Ferrari,
je me permets
de répondre au nom
du ministre Christophe Béchu,
qui est retenu
en ce moment même
au Sénat,
mais voici la réponse
qu'il vous aurait adressée s'il
avait pu être là aujourd'hui.
Un certain nombre
d'événements récents,
notamment l'épisode
des violences urbaines,
ont à nouveau mis
à jour la fragilité
des systèmes d'assurance
des collectivités territoriales.
Oui, le sujet est structurel.
Un nombre significatif
d'appels d'offres
sont infructueux
et les prix
et les franchises augmentent.
Ce phénomène
est effectivement lié
au risque climatique,
social, mais aussi
au risque juridique et judiciaire.
C'est également
lié à l'équilibre
et à la rentabilité d'un marché
de l'assurance resserré
autour de deux principaux
assureurs.
Le marché de la réassurance
s'est lui-même durci.
Vous avez raison
de dissocier la réponse
que doit apporter
le gouvernement
entre le court terme
et le moyen terme.
Sur le moyen terme,
le ministre de l'Economie
et le ministre
de la Transition écologique
et de la Cohésion
des territoires seront
très attentifs
aux préconisations
que soumettront
les personnes en charge
du futur rapport sur le sujet.
Nous devrons discuter avec vous,
le Parlement,
des mesures à prendre
pour atteindre nos objectifs.
Sur le court terme,
pour répondre
à l'urgence,
le gouvernement pilote
un groupe de travail
avec les assureurs
pour suivre le rythme
des dédommagements
et éviter
les résiliations sèches,
avec l'appui
de la direction générale
du Trésor.
Cet effort a déjà
produit des effets.
Nous sommes passés
de 3,5 du taux
de résiliation en 2022
à 2,9 en 2023.
Nous avons aussi
étendu le champ
des compétences du médiateur
des assurances,
qui s'empare
désormais des litiges
dans le cadre
des contrats existants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance des questions
au gouvernement est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.